[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Please
give a warm welcome to today's
speaker, a designer and
gardener, Leonie Cornelius.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Hi, all.
You're very welcome to
my talk on dream gardens.
I'm absolutely
delighted to be here.
It's a real honor.
And I have to admit, I've
never actually given this talk
to a group of people
that may or may not
have an interest in gardens.
So it's always been like garden
festivals and garden design
courses and things like that.
So over the past week or so,
I've been kind of going, oh,
my god, how am I going to make
these guys not fall asleep?
And how do I make it relevant
to what you guys actually do?
And it actually got me thinking
about the overlap and the core
of what we do as designers, as
people that offer a service.
And really what
it kind of boiled
down to for me was that
we offer an experience.
We provide an experience.
And that's something that's
really important to me,
because I'm really interested
in people and in how people
experience a space, a
garden, how they walk into it
and feel from an
emotional point of view.
And I think that has a lot of
overlap with what you guys do,
because what you're providing
is an online virtual experience.
And the overlap there is
that if it doesn't feel good,
and if it doesn't feel right,
the user is gone immediately.
So same thing in a garden.
If it's a badly
designed space, and it's
not natural to move
through and feels good,
you're just never going
to actually go out
into that space.
You can't move around
a space if it doesn't
circulate well, et cetera.
So there's a lot of
similarities and core principles
that overlap.
So within the virtual experience
and the tangible, the garden,
we have a lot of
overlaps, like making
a space or an experience, the
experience more usable, more
inspiring, more accessible,
more forward-thinking,
probably more so for you guys
than in my role as a garden
designer.
But having said that,
there's so much you
can do to think ahead,
even in garden design,
sustainability, et cetera.
More beautiful and obviously
more joyful, and by that,
I mean that you either go onto
a webpage, and it feels good,
or you go into a garden,
and it feels good.
And there's a huge
amount of that
in the book in how
you experience a space
and how it makes you feel.
And that's always
something I've been
interested in, because my
mom is a psychotherapist.
So we've always kind of talked
things to absolute death.
And it kind of bled
into my work as well.
So the talk-- in a way, I mean,
there's plenty of garden stuff
there, and most
of it is gardens.
But it's not just about gardens.
It's about people and
about experiences and about
emotional reactions to spaces.
So for today's
garden design talk,
the talk is about you,
because you guys are actually
the clients in this situation.
So I want you to think, right,
I want to design something
in this and come away with
something that can actually
be used in your own spaces.
So whether you have a
balcony or a little patio
or a huge field or
a friend's space
that you want to
think about, it's
worth kind of thinking
about that as we go along
and maybe just having
something to take away from it
that really inspires you.
So the most important
thing, I think,
is when I go into somebody's
space is, who is that person?
So I kind of try and
leave my ego at the door
when I go into somebody's space,
and it's all about that person.
So in this instance,
it's about you.
And you need to think
about, who am I?
If you're thinking about
designing a garden,
outdoor space for
yourselves, how do I live?
How do I spend my
day in the garden?
And that's often--
it's thought about,
but it's not given
enough attention.
So what you're thinking
about is, what do you like?
What's your lifestyle?
How do you spend
time in the garden?
Who are you on a personal level?
Do you have kids, pets?
Do you read or write sports?
So they're all incredibly
important elements
to consider when you go about
designing any kind of a space,
because that's kind of who
you are from a lifestyle
perspective.
But when I started
writing my book,
I kind of realized that a
lot of garden design books
go straight into that.
And yes, that's
really important,
but there's something else
which is really important
and which often does get
completely forgotten about.
And that's your
dreams for the space.
And a few people were
like, oh, your dreams.
Why?
Why do you have to
dream and all that?
You can just say, I
want that nice garden.
And again, probably, because
my mom's a psychotherapist,
I like to take that step
back and just think, no.
It's good to dream, and
it's good to open your mind
before you start going into
detail and into functions
and clotheslines
and compost bins
and all that stuff, which has
nothing to do with dreams.
It's just practical in function.
So in this instance, your
dreams are your vision
of your perfect space.
So gardens are
intensely personal,
just like interior design is.
They're part of you, part of
your home in the best scenario.
They're extensions
of your living space.
And that's why I think it's
really important to kind of go
into that in a
little bit of detail
before you start looking at
practicalities and functions
and things like that.
So they're different from
your functional requirements,
because they're personal,
and they're made up
of memories of times you've
spent in gardens, where you
felt amazing or just, say, your
grandmother's garden, where you
have a memory, a personal
connection to the past
or to people.
So there's a lot more to
it than just dreaming up
a nice little space.
But one massive thing,
even if you have a balcony,
even if you have a very small
patio, one thing I always say
is at this stage, dream big.
And I know you're not
going to have the Taj
Mahal on your balcony or
in a small patio space,
but you can take elements
of the biggest dream
that you can possibly have and
condense those elements down.
And there is an exercise
in my book, which
is called a Dream
Gardens Diagram, which
is just based around identifying
what it is you love about that.
So if you were looking
at that, and that
was the space that you
choose for the exercise,
then you can zoom
in on certain areas
and say, well, I
love the symmetry.
I love the detail of
the filigree work.
I love the planting.
I love the water, the
reflections, the calm,
whatever it is.
You can pull all those
together, and they
can become your concept.
So at this stage,
there are no limits.
And again, every time I
go into somebody's space,
they start going, OK,
and now I need the patio,
and now I need that, and I need
a circulation route to here.
And I always have to stop people
and go, no, just go back to--
be completely mad for
a while before you
start getting practical.
So there is no--
there are no limits
at this stage,
just dreaming up
your perfect space.
I never know why I include
this one, but for some reason
it always makes me zoom
out a bit in my own head.
So I've left it in
just for the sake
of kind of underlining that
idea of zooming out and not
getting into the nitty gritty
of detail at this point.
So the exercise that
I have in the book
is really based on just a
memory of a place, where
you were really, really happy.
So thinking of a garden
that you visited,
or a memory that you have
of having been in a garden,
and it doesn't even need
to be perfectly designed.
It can be completely wild
meadowscape or anything
like that.
And basically, what
you're doing is
you're thinking about what made
that space feel so good to you.
Why was it-- why did you have
a personal connection to it?
Was it the fun?
Was it the symmetries?
The wildness?
The dramas?
So each space-- and
that's something
you guys can do later on, if you
want, or take the books home,
and it's all kind of
outlined in that, too.
And it's a really
good-- it sounds
like a very simple
exercise, but it's
a really good way of
allowing yourself to not
design before you design.
So just going, oh,
I love that space.
I really enjoyed that space.
So this is my one,
unless somebody else
wants to give me one.
I love the Alhambra
in the south of Spain,
which is an amazing, absolutely
amazing garden and palace.
And they're Moorish gardens.
They're really symmetrical,
but yet the planting
is really wild and free.
So I love that
combination of those kind
of perfect architecture
and then the wild planting.
So for me, it was the
timeless feel of it--
the balance, the water, the
wild planting, the harmony.
And this is the exercise.
What you're doing is a
simple sketch spider diagram,
and you're putting the
characteristics of the space
above and the moods below.
So the moods of
this space actually
become your concept
of your garden design.
So you need to think,
right, that's what I
want to bring to my own space.
And even if it is a
balcony, there's balance.
There's calm.
You want to feel at ease.
You want to feel happier.
You want to feel freer.
If, say, you went for a meadow
that you felt incredibly
happy in and a
memory that you have,
there's so many ways of
bringing elements of a meadow--
the movement of the grasses,
looking at the wide, open sky.
Why not try and create
something that kind of emulates
that feeling, even if it is a
tiny balcony or a small patio?
So really, that's just about
taking those and bringing them
into your concept.
So for me, it was the
Alhambra, creating
a calm space inspired
by a Moorish palace,
yet the planting is wild.
So there's not too much
perfection going on,
which can become
boring, and you're never
going to actually be able to
achieve and maintain anyway.
So that's your
new found concept.
So that was my scenario
there-- a calm space inspired
by the Alhambra gardens in Spain
with wild, natural planting,
plenty of water,
and a timeless feel.
So really simple but
there's so many elements
then that you can choose,
pick out, and build
into your design.
So that informs your materials,
your colors, your water
features.
It's easy then, because
I think a lot of people
don't know where to start.
So this is a great way of
kind of identifying a concept
and then going, right,
the paving I need to get
needs to match that feel, and
the water needs to match that,
and everything needs to follow
that feel and underline that.
And then a concept of the
garden works naturally,
and it's not disjointed.
So the next part is
Form Follows Function,
which Louis Sullivan said.
And as you guys know, within the
internet, you go into a page,
it doesn't work, you're
gone immediately.
So the same thing applies
to a badly designed garden.
If it's badly designed,
if it doesn't work,
never mind the look or
the beauty or whatever.
It can be beautiful, but if it
doesn't work, it's annoying,
and you just don't want
to be in the space.
So basically, our gardens, from
a tangible perspective, are--
they're spaces for living,
and they need to work.
It's really simple.
And the first thing I get my
clients to do is do out a list,
and--
I'm sorry, the second
thing after dreaming.
Get them to do a
list of how they
spend their day in the garden.
So basically how they--
the most boring stuff--
I hang my washing out.
The dog goes around.
The kids go to the trampoline,
all of those kind of things.
But also to say, I
like to entertain.
So it'd be nice to have a
pool to dangle our legs in,
et cetera.
That's us at the Bloom garden
this year dangling our legs.
So I had to include that.
So that's just really
an idea of what
your day looks like in the
garden and all the things
the garden needs to function
for you. [? Like, ?]
So the functions of the
garden, and then the list
of functional requirements.
That's it.
Basically, really
simple, really easy.
List out everything you
need in the actual garden,
and it doesn't need
to be super detailed.
But you need this
because the next step
is putting it onto paper.
And when you put
it onto paper, you
need to take off each and
every single one of those.
And if one of them is
missing, then the garden
is not going to work 100%.
So that was a client of mine
in Strand Hill and Sligo.
The job was kind of half done.
The builder's still outside.
The dog, which they
weren't supposed
to have a dog-- the whole
garden was based around them
not having kids or a dog.
They now have a child and a dog.
And he destroyed
the garden, but this
was before we did the garden.
And you can see there's nothing
there, and it looks horrendous.
The house is getting there.
Everything is brilliant, but a
lot of spaces that you see you
have to assess really,
really well in order
to get the design right.
So you're looking at everything
from soil samples, aspect,
garden climate--
probably pretty boring at this
stage, but it's so important.
So even if you have
a small balcony,
you need to make
sure that you address
things like wind,
privacy, views to make
sure you don't make any
mistakes and then end up
with the neighbor
right there looking in
at you, even though you wanted
this enclosed private haven.
So there are things you need
to list out at the very start.
Obviously, for bigger sites,
it gets a lot more complicated,
and you need to
put in more detail.
Sometimes we get
surveyors in, because it's
too detailed to do with slopes
and all that kind of stuff.
But for small spaces, it's
relatively easy to do.
The main thing-- common sense.
You're looking at views.
Does it have light?
So you're looking at the
strengths of the space.
And how can you enhance them?
That's really important.
And then you're also
looking at the challenges.
So you can see the two there.
We do a show called RT Super
Garden, and pretty much all
the gardens we go into look
like that-- absolute disasters.
And after the show leaves,
then they're ta-da.
Yeah, right.
Five weeks later,
blood, sweat, and tears.
But yeah, that's actually
the joy of it anyway.
It's television, transformation,
and we all love that.
But as I say, nothing
is unsolvable.
And the main thing is having
that vision and the dream
for what is to come.
And I think some
people find that easier
than others to imagine.
Like my mom cannot imagine
what a garden will look like.
She's like, how can you even
visualize how it will be?
Yeah, probably
because I studied it.
So yeah, it's all about
building on strengths
and overcoming challenges in
gardens and garden design.
Site measurements-- I touched
on that briefly just there.
It can be incredibly
complicated,
and it can be very, very simple
to just doing a scaled sketch,
putting in your sizes,
your heights, and where
the entrance, exit,
where the pathways are.
And then the first thing
is getting the site right.
It's doing a very
simple scale sketch
and exploring what's
happening on the site.
So I'm not going to
go into big detail,
because that is actually boring.
But it's good to know,
and it's detailed
in the book as well
just to know that that's
how you have to
start if you want
to take on a plot of
any considerable size.
Which actually that's kind of
a realistic, large city garden
that you could kind of
measure out yourself
as opposed to getting
somebody in to do it for you.
So after that comes the
functional layout plan,
which is basically taking
the functions-- so what
the garden has to do for you
and plunking them on the plan.
And they're bubbles.
They're not designed.
They're not beautiful.
They're not details.
They're basically sketched
bubbles telling you
exactly what happens on site.
So where you need privacy,
where you want a patio,
where you want screening,
where you need a wind screen.
So all the things that you
looked at that were challenges
need to be addressed
on this in a bubble.
So it doesn't need to represent
the shape or anything.
So it's actually
really easy to do.
But it's so
informative to when you
start going to sketch
detail, and you
start putting in details in it.
So that brings me to
the bigger picture--
great design, quite far
away from the bubbles.
This is one of my
favorite pictures.
It's Tom Stuart-Smith,
who's a UK-based designer.
And it's just such
a beautiful picture,
because it shows how a garden
can blend into the landscape
beyond without-- it
just feels like it's
a part of the landscape.
And I'll go back to
that in a minute.
So what makes good design,
and are we born designers?
It's an interesting
question, because I
don't think we're
necessarily born designers.
Some people are better
at it than others,
but it's definitely
something you can learn.
And what does help-- and
I'm sure a lot of you guys
are design-based or
from design backgrounds.
So you'd be aware of a lot of
these principles, and the fact
that they do kind of
influence everything from car
design to pen
design to everything
has those principles.
And again, it goes back to
what works and functions.
It goes back to the
principles of these four
and then another one
I'll talk about after.
The first one we'll
look at briefly
is the unity and
harmony, and we'll
talk about it just
in the garden setting
and how it works with the house,
the garden, and the setting.
And that's the picture
I showed you before.
This is the same one in
winter at the bottom.
Again, Tom Stuart-Smith
in the top one, too,
and it just shows how
the house, first of all,
is linked with the garden.
You can see the
colors, the textures,
pick up on the red brick,
the grasses, and the water,
and the sizes.
So you've got a connection
between the house
and the garden,
the design space.
And then beyond that you have a
connection of the design garden
with the landscape beyond.
So in the landscape
beyond, for example, you've
got darker spots of big trees.
And Tom's brought that into
the foreground of the garden
by having darker shapes, the
topiary shapes in the front,
and then the lighter
ponds, which kind of echo
what's going on behind.
So that creates
unity and harmony,
because you're blending
all of that together.
Simplicity-- I mean
the Persian gardens are
a huge influence
for me and I think
are a great example
of simplicity.
Less is more, and
I think that really
applies to online as well.
There's so much being
chucked at you all the time
that it's really nice to have a
calm, simple design sometimes.
There's nothing I like more
than looking at a website that's
just like, ah, calm.
Not too many ads, not too many
things being thrown at you.
But of course, there has
to be a balance, which
brings me to now.
It should bring me to
balance, really, shouldn't it?
Scale and proportion.
So really the same
thing as the links
between the house
and the setting
and the views beyond the garden.
It's the relationship
between the house.
So you don't want the house
to be absolutely gigantic
and the person to
feel really small.
Same thing with
planting-- so trees
can't be tiny and the house
really big or vice versa.
So there's got to be a
relationship between everything
that's happening in the
space, the landscape beyond.
And then also, obviously, the
house and the person because we
can't forget that it's you
that's experiencing that space.
And the best way
of doing that is
to start sketching or thinking
in 3-D as opposed to 2-D
flat way.
There's Alice.
And there's balance.
So balance is really all about
everything coming together
in a pleasing composition,
and there's so much--
that work that comes into that
from all the other things we
looked at-- scale
and proportion.
It's actually really
easy to get balance
right when you have
a symmetrical garden,
so the likes of the Alhambra.
If you take that as
inspiration, it's
quite easy to get it
right, because you've
got that inherent symmetry.
Whilst if you kind of push it to
being asymmetrical, the design,
it does get a little bit harder,
because you need to make sure
you get the balance of the
forms, the shapes, the sizes,
and all of that right.
So it does get a
little bit trickier.
You'll also have mystery,
excitement, light and darkness,
balance and color,
and structures also
need to be balanced.
So there are great
ways, I think,
to start looking at design.
I don't know what percentage
of you guys are design-based
or have a background in design.
So I should have probably
asked that at the start.
I'm sure you're aware of some
of these or most of these,
but they're a great thing to
even-- even if you do know,
and you're aware of them--
to make sure you remind yourself
of on a kind of regular basis.
The other thing that I always
find fascinating to look at
is the golden ratio.
And again, you're
probably all aware of it,
but I find it quite
interesting in garden design,
because you're looking at
nature to inform nature.
So from ferns and the way
they grow to succulents.
There was actually
a garden at Chelsea,
which was based all around
the mathematics of geometry,
which had the succulent
on the right there.
It had a lot of those
kind of shapes and forms,
and the mathematics
behind it are just--
I don't do math.
To me, it's absolutely
baffling, but it's incredible.
It's really inspiring to look
at and to apply to projects.
And the fact that
it's also found
in our bodies, and the
fact that it repeats,
and it's just incredible.
I find it really,
really interesting
that when you
clench your fist, it
forms into a perfect
golden ratio curl.
But that can inform--
that does and can inform
a huge amount of design.
And I very cheekily stuck
it on top of Google.
So I don't know if that actually
does, but it kind of works.
But it works in garden
design, the Apple logo.
So that's-- car design
and everything--
it kind of influences
everything.
And the reason
for that is really
because we're using what is
inherently found in nature,
and that's informing design.
So it's an interesting cycle.
So the next thing is choosing
shapes for the garden.
So we've gone and looked at
the functions of the garden
and putting that in in
bubbles and how it works
and how we make sure
everything is included that you
want and need in the garden.
And the next bit is how to
actually put that into a plan
that you can work from.
And personally, I go
through the same thing,
and I recognized this a couple
of years ago when I went,
OK, that's what's happening.
I go through the
same kind of problem
every time I have a design job.
I start off going, this
is going to be amazing.
It's going to be
such a good project.
And then I start sketching,
and I start doing stuff.
And I'm like, oh, my god,
it's going to be a disaster.
It's going to be horrendous.
The client is going to hate us.
And then I start
doing more on it
and force myself through that,
and I come out the other end
and go, OK, it's
going to be fine.
It'll be great.
It'll be good.
So I think a huge amount
of people go through that.
I think designers
in general always
go through that kind
of stage of self-doubt.
And the hardest part is
actually this, which, for me,
personally, is
putting the shapes
and making decisions as opposed
to just messing and playing.
So I was happy when I
learned that it is actually
very easy to do.
That basically you take
the functional layout plan
with the bubbles, and you sketch
over that with either a layout
paper or a tracing paper.
And you just explore
the shapes based on what
you have from those bubbles.
Because you know you want
the patio at the back door,
because that's where you want
to go from the kitchen, where
the door is.
So you know you want it there.
You just need to
decide on shapes.
You need to decide how
they link to each other.
So you've already made a lot of
decisions without knowing it.
You've placed the patio
where it wants to go.
You've put the
trampoline where you can
see the kids from the kitchen.
You've done all of
that background work
without realizing.
So you just explore, and
you start looking at shapes
and what works.
I can see the square.
It's free-form,
circles, combination.
You can have completely
free-form shapes.
It's really what appeals to
you and mostly, actually,
what your concept wants.
So if you have a very
loose meadow-style garden,
and you want it to
feel really wild,
then unless you're
doing it on purpose,
you're not going to produce
large concrete slabs, which
I actually love the idea of.
But then you'd be breaking
those rules for a reason
if that's what you wanted to do.
So it depends on
what the concept
is to make it work for you.
And then after that, if
you've chosen your shapes,
you've decided where everything
goes, comes the really, really
exciting part, because
you've got your concept.
You know how it's
supposed to feel,
and you get to play
around, basically,
with materials,
colors, planting,
and it just all
follows your concept.
So in my case, if
it's the Alhambra--
god, I'd love an Alhambra
garden, actually,
now that I think about it.
Don't Google my garden,
whatever you do.
I don't know if technology
is that advanced yet
to zoom in right down.
Is it?
It's in a mess.
But basically, it all
comes down to your concept
and how to bring that concept to
life through materials, colors,
and planting.
Is it really?
Like, can you actually
see different plants?
AUDIENCE: Let me
have your address.
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
No, no, no, it's OK.
Not much to see.
I've had a very busy year.
That's crazy.
I digress.
So the concept--
again, that goes back
to the idea of kind
of fleshing out
the whole design
to suit your feel
and to suit what your dream is.
So if it was a seaside garden,
what do you bring into it?
Do you bring in pebbles?
And then also think-- and I
go into this in the book--
don't be afraid to go for all
the materials that are expected
and then take some out
and break the rules.
And if it was a
seaside garden, it's
pebbles and ropes and all that.
Get rid of the ropes and
replace it with rusted metal,
or get rid of the
expected pebble
and replace it with concrete.
Or do something that
makes it new and fresh
and not the expected.
I don't think I say
it there, but that's
outlined in the book.
And it's actually
a big part of, I
think, what makes really good
garden design is breaking
the rules once you
know them, once you
know what you want to achieve.
So being selective--
if you're going
to go for colors and
materials, choose
two colors, two strong colors
and two strong materials.
Don't go mad, because you
want the concept to be really,
really strong,
and you can always
add little bits here and there.
You can always
create little rooms
that have separate feels,
but you can see it in this--
the strength of that
rusted corten steel,
and then picking up on
that tiny little planting
bits in that same color
just balances so well.
This one, again, you can see
the designer, Luciano Giubbilei,
has chosen loads a kind
of neutral, muted tones.
They're different colors but
loads of different materials.
But they all work, because
they're all neutrals.
So again, the palette is
really simple, really clean.
Same designer-- again,
he loves neutrals.
But it really allows structure
and form to jump out at you.
While as if there was
too many colors there,
you wouldn't see
those ball shapes.
You wouldn't see the
multi-stem trees.
And then this one,
Luis Barragan--
he's a Mexican architect--
so he chose loads of different
colors for the space,
but he used one material.
So the colors are--
there's plenty of color--
the color of the
sky and the water
and loads of colors
but the same material
pretty much throughout.
And then the last
slide is really
to show that vegetable growing
can actually be pretty, too.
It doesn't have to be
a kind of ugly plot.
You can actually
use cool materials
like the wicker and the
timber and the terracotta
and make it really
colorful and pretty.
So the last bit I'll go into
is the planting perfection,
choosing planting.
So again, the planting
that you choose
needs to follow your concept.
So if your concept is you
want a jungle haven in Ranola,
you need to make sure all the
plants you choose not only
work for Ireland,
work for the space,
but that they also
work for the concept.
And so you study what works,
how the jungle looks--
big leaves, the
foliage, the bamboo,
and how to make that work.
And it's totally workable.
I just wrote an article
about that, actually,
and it can work really,
really well and look
really lush and jungle-like.
And again, for the
planting, we're
also considering the
principles of design,
which are really important.
So one more thing is
right plant, right place.
And it's really about a
huge amount of interest
these days has been put
into creating sustainable
gardens that grow themselves as
opposed to having to maintain
all the time, and
it's really opened up
a lot of new kind of
avenues for young designers,
like Chelsea and Bloom and all
those places, where you're not
stuck in kind of old traditions,
which don't work, really,
unless you have huge
amounts of time.
So that's what we're
talking about here
is the idea of having organic
ecosystems that just grow,
and that you can let die down in
winter, and they come back up.
And there's that cycle,
that natural cycle, and yet
feel like they've
been there forever.
That bottom one is
a Chelsea garden.
You know, you'd never think--
it looks like it's in the
middle of the Provence.
And so there's a few
different planting styles,
and I'll just go through them
really quickly, because they're
all in the book.
And there's so many
of them in the book,
and I've pulled out like
four or five of them.
And basically, the
cottage-style planting,
which is that real old English,
formal style, and looks
like it's kind of
been scattered there.
But it's actually
pretty high maintenance,
because you've got
kind of the box balls,
and all the
perennials dying down,
and the bulbs that
have to be taken up,
and all that kind of stuff.
Modernist-style planting,
which is very clean, very
modern-- a lot of
that gets combined
with kind of naturalistic,
kind of wild meadow planting,
which works really well.
You can see the top one
there is a Chelsea garden,
and they've kind of done that.
That's the
naturalistic planting,
which really echoes what's
happening in nature.
And the idea of
naturalistic planting
is that it does just scatter and
grow and evolve into something
fresh and new, and
that has really
been a focus on planting styles
in the past 10 years or so.
That it's gone away from that
uber planned and maintained
idea to a more kind of letting
nature do what it wants to do
and embracing that.
So that brings me back to
the core of what we do.
And just if there's
anything that I'd
love you guys to go away
with today after the talk
is that connection between,
first of all, everything
that we do as
people, whether it's
garden design or
an online platform
or any other creative or
design-based endeavor,
that there is always
that connection.
And the connection is the
person and the experience.
And much like garden design,
everything is personal,
and to keep that
connection in mind.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I was dreading that.
I'm good now.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That was great.
That was really--
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Thank you.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: I'll let
you go here into the middle.
That was great,
really entertaining
and really informative.
So we're going to open up to
audience questions in a minute.
I'm just going to ask,
maybe, the first question.
So the reality for some people--
me-- is that I love the idea
of having a beautiful garden,
or like we talked
about, my little patio.
But I do struggle to keep
the odd potted plant alive.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: OK.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Is this book beyond me?
Is it a baby step, the pre-book?
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Oh, god, no.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
What will I do?
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
Well, that goes back
to the right plant, right place,
finding out what plants really
need, I guess.
So identifying what the
plant that you choose--
what the needs are,
what the soil needs
are, what the
moisture levels are,
making sure there's
enough drainage,
making sure that
it doesn't dry out.
So if you do have, say, a
pot, you can control that.
So that's easy.
You just need to
inform yourself.
So use Google and find out
exactly what the plant needs.
I actually use it
on a daily basis
for all sorts of stuff from
cooking to god knows what.
But yeah, to inform yourself
of what that plant needs.
Or to go, right, I
don't have huge amounts
of rainfall in that
particular area in the garden
where I have the pots.
And to go, right, I'm going to
use drought-friendly plants,
and then find out what
you could plant there.
And then create a scheme
around that-- so a dry desert
feel space with grasses
or something like that.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
So it goes back
to what you said a while ago
about just the knowledge.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Yeah, yeah.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
And for me, baby steps.
Tiny little baby steps.
I'm going to ask
one more question,
and then I'll go
to the audience.
If a community-- and I just
say a group of people who live
in a housing estate--
decided to create a small
community garden or allotment,
would you have any
advice on what they could
do to make that a success?
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Oh, planning.
Planning.
Definitely a huge thing.
Make sure that you know
exactly what you're doing
and look at who's
going to be using it.
So going back to the
user, is it going
to be the younger
people in the community?
Will they be involved?
Is it going to be older people?
So you might raise beds.
So finding out the user is
probably the main thing,
identifying who will be using
it, and then making it fun,
making sure that the
kids get involved,
and everybody wants to be there.
So maybe have some sort of
a social space or something
in it, like a small gazebo
or a little polytunnel,
where everyone can hang out.
Because then you'll
want to be there,
and you'll want to put work in.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's great.
Have we got any questions
from the audience?
Oh, we've got one here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my
first question to ask--
you probably get asked
this one all the time.
Is that on?
LEONIE CORNELIUS: I
can hear you, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Great.
What's your take
on synthetic grass?
Because it's sort of when you're
doing a lot of other stuff,
it seems like an easy option,
but is it the right option?
LEONIE CORNELIUS: It's funny,
because a lot of garden
designers, we had a big
discussion about this
during Super Garden.
And 90% of the people that we
were talking to at the time
were like, oh, it's horrible.
It's horrible.
But there's an
absolute place for it.
Like Today FM have it
on their roof garden,
and they were ashamed of it.
And I was like, no, but why
would you put real grass there?
It would be head-wrecking.
So I think it depends
on your needs,
on your needs, on
what you need it for.
And if you think it'll make
your life easier and better,
and you can work it into
the design in such a way
that it looks good,
then absolutely.
Why not?
I couldn't be a snob about it.
I think a lot of people do, and
they almost do it to pretend.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: Great.
Got one in the second row here.
We just have to check if
the microphone is working
before we get it to you.
AUDIENCE: I can shout.
That's fine.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
We just want
to make sure that we hear
you on the recording.
That's all.
Thank you.
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
Totally natural.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Oh, it's working.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for the talk.
It looks absolutely
amazing and makes
me wish to just drop my job
and start gardening all week.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: You
can come work for me.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Hire me.
What can we do?
Like most of us,
we can't probably
afford at this stage to garden
in Dublin, let alone anything
in Dublin.
What can we do to create a
nice space on our balconies,
or if we don't even have
a balcony, maybe inside,
like a small oasis
to relax and enjoy
what we saw on the slides?
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
Well, first thing
is I'm concerned with
that quite a lot,
because I hate
the idea of design
being exclusive and the
idea that only those that
have like 100,000 euro to spend
on the design could afford it.
And the first garden
I did-- actually,
I don't think there's any
pictures of it in this--
a bloom was made with
old scaffolding planks.
And so if you want to
create something really
special without putting huge
amounts of money into it,
you have to kind of rethink
the materials you're using.
You have to rethink
the amount of time
you want to put into it.
So those scaffolding planks--
they looked absolutely stunning
when we were done with them.
But we sanded and
sanded and sanded
and sanded to get them
to look really well,
and then stained them
again and again and again.
So reimagining old
materials is great,
but then everybody's
kind of started
catching on to that, too.
So scaffolding planks
are hard to get.
What do you call them?
Pallets.
But be creative.
Get hands-on yourself,
and it doesn't need
to cost a huge amount of money.
It's hard to be specific,
because I don't know exactly
what you're talking about.
But say, instead of--
if you wanted something
on a windowsill inside,
instead of just getting
a plastic window box,
create something,
even if it's made
with driftwood or made
with timber that you stain up
to suit the color scheme inside.
Or go to Pinterest and
research certain things.
And there's so
many ideas you can
kind of bring in to the home by
just getting creative yourself.
I know that's a
really bad answer.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
So it's about making
it a for-real project.
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
Creativity, yes.
Yes.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
Not just a quick fix,
which is what I kind of tend
to do when buying a new plant.
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
But in that way
you can work design
principles into it,
and then you'll create
something beautiful, as
opposed to just
placing something
that somebody else mightn't have
put a huge amount of thought
into.
So it's the thought process, and
then making it personal to you.
Because if you make it yourself
or have it made, even if it is,
like, say, a gate,
a rusted steel gate,
it might be old materials,
but you thought it up.
So you know it's going
to be perfect for you.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: OK, lovely.
Anymore audience questions?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So I'm moving
into a new house.
We just bought a new
house just down the road.
And we've got a roughly
basic square garden,
nothing spectacular.
Right now, it's rubble.
Myself and my wife
were talking about what
we do from the start.
So, for example, obviously,
we'd be busy inside the house.
But do you have
any advice in terms
of if we wanted to put down,
let's say, trees first,
we start from big and
work our way down?
Or do we start with
little potted plants
and work our way up?
Have you kind of come
across that before?
Where would you start?
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Oh, loads.
And the main thing, I think,
is before you start planting,
before you start doing
anything is dreaming that,
that kind of figuring out
what you want from the garden
before you start placing
things, and even before you
start going into the privacy
and all of those kind of things.
So making sure that your
dream for the house, which
you probably already
have, and you
have materials and
features in there
that you want to pick up on
and the style of the house.
Try and bleed that out.
So pick up on colors,
materials on the floor.
Like if you have, say,
concrete floors, bleed it out.
Or if there's tiles or
timber, try and continue that,
because then it will become an
extension of your living space.
But making sure you identify
what kind of feel you want,
what kind of style
you want, and then
bleeding that in
through the whole space
and connecting them.
And then you can always
start by planting a few trees
if you wanted to now.
And then work with
the rest around that.
But just make sure
that you don't end up
putting them somewhere
where you don't want them.
So making sure you
follow the process
in your head a little bit
of, where do I need privacy?
Where do I need windscreen?
So do analyze the site
a bit before you look
at trees or that sort of thing.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
OK, we probably
have time for one more question.
Any final audience questions?
No?
Oh, yeah.
Two more, actually.
We'll fit them.
We'll fit them both in.
AUDIENCE: It's a very
practical question.
I was wondering, like,
is there any place
that you would
recommend us to go
to if we want to design, for
example, our little balcony
or so, like a garden center we
can go to that you could really
recommend?
Because I looked for plants,
and I finally went to Ikea.
And they were all sold out.
So that wasn't really a success.
So maybe there is a
better place to go
to that's also affordable.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: You're
talking about outdoor plants?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
outdoor, just as indoor.
I don't know.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Yeah,
I mean there's loads
of places in or around Dublin.
There's a place
called Garden World.
I don't know if you've
come across Garden World
and Kilquade.
In Kilcoole?
Kilquade.
Can't remember.
I think it's-- yeah, in Wicklow.
They're fantastic.
They have incredible plants,
good quality plants, too.
I generally deal more
with the wholesale end
of things, so larger plants,
but they're fantastic.
And they have a huge selection,
and they're very knowledgeable.
So they'll actually help talk
you through whatever you need.
Materials-wise I
love Salvage Yards.
So if you have ideas for a
balcony or something like that,
go to old architectural
salvage and just choose
that interesting,
cool, even one thing,
and then build around
it if you don't
have a specific idea in mind.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: If
you can just pass the mic.
AUDIENCE: A place more
in the city center-ish
would be Plant Life
on Cork Street.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Closer by you
if you don't have a car.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My question
kind of comes back
to what we discussed earlier.
It's like around
style, about style.
Is there like an Irish
style that you've
seen over the years, or
how has that developed?
Or is there something that
makes Irish gardens stand out
from other, let's
say, European gardens?
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
It's interesting,
because for a long
time, Irish design
would have been influenced
hugely by the likes of Chelsea,
the RHS shows, Tatton Park, and
all of the big shows, garden
shows, show garden
shows in the UK.
I think since Bloom was
launched, which is what?
11 years ago now.
I think that kind of gave
Irish designers a platform
here to showcase.
So I think there's been
a huge shift in that.
And I think an Irish planting
style and feel has developed,
which is a little bit more
relaxed and natural than, say,
its English counterpart.
Having said that, trends
kind of cross over and back,
and you've got trends coming
from the south of France,
and there's like an overall
trend of naturalistic planting
and sustainability,
and allowing gardens
to just be the way
they want to be,
which, actually, last year,
came back a little bit
to be more structured, again.
So there are trends that
go across all of them.
But I do think
Irish designers have
developed their own styles.
And I think this year at Bloom,
it was interesting to see.
There was a lot of
interest at Chelsea,
and the Chelsea designers were
tweeting a lot about designers
here and about what
gardens they liked
and stuff, which was
amazing to have that coming
back to Ireland.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN:
That's great.
Thank you.
Thank you, Leonie,
for your time.
LEONIE CORNELIUS: Thank you.
KAROLINE O'SULLIVAN: And thanks,
everyone, for your questions.
LEONIE CORNELIUS:
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]